alexis et poulain éditorialistes alexis
s'est confirmée par des sources proches
de l'enquêté
l'assaillant qui a donc sévi ce matin
dans le centre ville de nice à
l'intérieur d'une église aurait crié
allah akbar le parquet antiterroriste
le parquet antiterroriste a donc été
saisie c'est un nouveau fait dramatique
qui intervient à peine deux semaines
après le meurtre de samuel tati c'était
avec samuel patil l'éducation qui
symboliquement étaient visés cette fois
ci c'est d'église oui c'est évidemment
tous les symboles qui sont visés les uns
après les autres par ces fous du djihad
qui crient allah ouakbar et qui tue les
gens avec des couteaux je crois que
c'est la répétition en fait de ce mode
opératoire qui fatiguent les citoyens
français qui les use et qui est
difficile pour le pouvoir parce qu'au
delà des déclarations martiales qui a pu
avoir après la décapitation du
professeur samuel pâtit on voit bien que
arrêté identifier et faire en sorte que
ces loups solitaires c'est fou armé de
couteaux ne passe à l'acte est
extrêmement difficile pour les services
de renseignement pour les forces de
police et pour le gouvernement le il
suffit simplement d'acheter dans le
commerce un couteau et de décider
d'aller tuer des gens innocents
un matin au petit matin voilà c'était
dans la basilique notre dame à nice
parce que évidemment le lieu est choisi
un pour choquer les esprits pour
provoquer un lieu de culte catholique
cette fois après les cols tous tout le
mode de vie en fait volontairement
attaqué par ces terroristes pour semer
la discorde pour semer la dissension
pour que la colère en fou et que nos
gouvernements et bien déclare une guerre
de civilisation il ne faut surtout pas
déclarent être parce que ce serait faire
le jeu de ces terroristes qui
n'attendent que ça je crois
qu'aujourd'hui vous le voyez la
population française d'ailleurs et
réagit avec un calme et une dignité
énorme contre ces attaques indignes et
insupportables de la part des
djihadistes et maintenant évidemment la
question se pose de la réponse policière
sécuritaires militaires de l'état
français pour
que cesse sur notre territoire ces
attaques qui met en jeu la vie des
citoyens français innocents alors les
faits se sont déroulés dans et aux
abords de l'église notre dame à nice
c'est aussi
un fait qui intervient à quelques jours
de la célébration par les catholiques de
la toussaint oui les fêtes religieuses
se succèdent en cette fin d'année mais
pas seulement
côté catholique évidemment l'idée encore
une fois n'est pas de rentrer dans cette
guerre de religion les djihadistes qui
utilisent l'islam comme ils le font ça
lisse cette religion salissent toutes
les religions une religion elle n'a pas
pour principe de tuer les gens à la cour
principe de réunir et de faire en sorte
qu'il y ait un dialogue des cultures est
pas cette guerre volontaires voulue par
ces idiots c'est fou armé de couteaux
qui ne font que nier la vie humaine que
lui nier la valeur que nous donnons nous
à la vie humaine est aujourd'hui la
plupart des croyants pratiquants ou non
de toutes les religions sont simplement
chauffe pied par par ces djihadistes à
répétition par ses tours au couteau à
répétition qui n'ont plus rien à faire
sur le territoire national et c'est bien
là toute la question comment faire pour
que cessent ces attaques comment faire
pour que ces dangereux criminels soient
éloignés soit mis en prison soit mis
hors d'état de nuire
c'est la question à laquelle doivent
répondre les autorités au delà des
déclarations encore une fois on a vu à
la le volontarisme ces derniers jours de
gérald darmanin dans la dissolution
d'associations dites et islamistes
baraka city le ccf la volonté d'éloigner
deux cent trente et une personnes
fichées s radicaliser s pour islamisme
que va-t-il se passer après cette
nouvelle attaque seulement quinze jours
après la décapitation du professeur le
ras-le-bol évidemment est totale la peur
aussi et total l'époque et est une
catastrophe pour les nations européennes
pour la france en particulier après le
couvre-feu après le confinement locaux
vides qui n'en finit pas et maintenant
une attaque supplémentaire avec en plus
des pays qui ont montré du doigt la
france
que ce soit la turquie de recep tayyip
erdogan est aussi le qatar l'arabie
saoudite
on apprend aussi qu à jeddah un
personnel de sécurité du consulat de
france vient d'être attaquée ce matin à
avignon un homme aussi s'est jeté sur
des policiers avec un couteau il a été
tué par la police
donc on est on est dans une évolution du
djihad ou la france a été de nouveau
montré du doigt comme l'ennemi ça suffit
je crois qu'il est temps que la
république française se défendent que
les partenaires européens aussi se
défendent
on ne peut plus tolérer cela et c'est
parce qu emmanuel macron et parce que
gérald darmanin ont décidé d'être
volontariste contre l'islamisme radical
contre cet islam politique que les
attaques vont se succéder
et bien il ne faudra pas céder et c'est
terrible parce que voilà que nous sommes
à nouveau en état de siège
alors même que se tient le procès des
attentats de charlie hebdo
alors vous évoquez à l'instant en
filigrane notamment ces manifestations
qui sont en cours dans certains pays
arabes certains pays musulmans contre
emmanuel macron contre la france contre
les propos que le chef de l'état a tenu
lors de l'hommage national rendu à
samuel apathie emmanuel macron qui a
défendu le droit à la liberté
d'expression le droit à caricaturer
aussi quel rôle peuvent jouer ces
manifestations menées en dehors de la
france
quel rôle peuvent jouer quelle incidence
est ce que ça peut avoir sur notre
territoire
aucun c'est très simple c'est de c'est
de l'agitation à la baba prix pour
mobiliser des fanatiques
je ne crois pas que la france ait fait
la leçon à l'arabie saoudite sur
l'application de la charia sur son
territoire sur la peine de mort sur son
territoire soit la façon dont les femmes
sont fêtés en arabie saoudite donc c'est
de l'ingérence internationale qui est en
train d'être fait pour pousser la france
à accepter un droit au blasphème 20 ou
plutôt un délit de blasphème
alors qu'il n'existe pas dans le droit
français nous sommes en france nos lois
sont celles de la république
eh bien nous les ferons respecter et
nous n'avons pas de leçons à recevoir de
pays qui pointe du doigt notre notre
pays pour son mode dit parce que la
france ne fait pas ça et ne pointe pas
du doigt les régimes qui met en place la
charia par exemple donc il ya des
instances internationales pour discuter
que ce soit les nations unies les
conférences internationales
et la france n'a pas à céder à ces
pressions internationales le problème
c'est que oui ça fait de notre pays une
cible alexis blanc quelle organisation
internationale quelle institution a le
poids nécessaire pour faire face et
s'imposer face à un mouvement alors est
ce qu'on peut vraiment parler de
mouvement est ce que ces épisodes i
qu'est ce que c'est anecdotique
est ce qui se passe en ce moment dans
c'est lors de ces manifestations anti
anti emmanuel macron est-ce que c'est
l'union européenne qui aujourd'hui
doit intervenir et agir franchement et
comment est ce qu elle peut le faire
oui l'union européenne doit réagir au
delà des des mots de soutien qui a pu
avoir ne pas les 1000 heures de vie des
européens qui ont soutenu et le même axe
maintenant il est temps que l'europe
réagissent mais l'europe est encore une
fois pieds et poings liés dans ce
problème là
si vous voyez par exemple la turquie
d'erdogan elle est en position de force
parce que l'europe à sous traiter le
problème migratoire à la turquie donc
aujourd'hui erdogan peut dire ce qu'il
veut montrer du doigt et meymac où on
faire une campagne de boycott des
produits français
parce que et les allemands sont coincés
avec erdogan pour le rôle économique que
joue la turquie aujourd'hui et puis
l'europe toute l'europe est coincé parce
qu'elle a volontairement sous traiter le
problème migratoire dogan donc mais elle
a effectivement de sortir de ce chantage
qu'impose le président turc erdogan
c'est toute la question si on en sort
alors il faut mettre les moyens il faut
que l'europe prenne ses responsabilités
ce qu'elle n'a pas fait depuis des
années depuis quinze ans que dure vingt
ans que dure cette crise migratoire
qu'elle n'a pas pris ses responsabilités
selon vous c'est une question des moyens
à l'expert non alors les moyens on
pourrait les avoir les partenaires
européens sont extrêmement divisé sur
cette question parce que pendant des
années vous avez eu les pays frontières
ce qu'ils faisaient barrière que ce soit
la hongrie l'italie l'espagne la grèce
qui ont alerté de ce problème migratoire
et puis les autres pays qui finalement
ne les ont pas écouté les ont un peu
laissé tomber
ça a été le cas de l'italie qui ne
comprenaient pas finalement les
problématiques de ces pays frontières
donc aujourd'hui et malgré les
conférences qui a pu avoir sur sur la
pression migratoire la gestion de cette
crise migratoire par l'europe
on voit bien que ça n'avance pas parce
que les partenaires européens sont
divisés et c'est le cas aussi dans la
réponse face à la turquie d'erdogan
angela merkel est très gênée compte tenu
de l'importante communauté turque en
allemagne et des intérêts économiques de
l'allemagne avec la turquie aujourd'hui
pour faire la leçon à erdogan on l'a vu
lors des échauffourées en méditerranée à
la rentrée autour de la grèce donc tout
est extrêmement complexe parce que
l'europe n'est pas en ordre de bataille
parce que il y à une dissension non dit
entre les partenaires européens donc
aujourd'hui oui s'il devait y avoir une
réponse elle devrait être coordonnée au
niveau européen pour dire que nous
tenons à nos valeurs à notre liberté
d'expression et que si les djihadisme
déclare la guerre et bien nous allons
répondre avec nos moyens parce qu'encore
une fois cette guerre il est impossible
à mener en réalité quand vous avez des
gens qui décident au petit matin
d'attaquer au couteau dans des lieux de
culte devant des écoles ou ailleurs il
est extrêmement difficile de prévoir et
d'empêcher que ces fous commettre le
pire
donc notre réponse elle est d'un côté la
vigilance avec daisy pirates mais on ne
peut pas mettre des militaires devant
tous les toutes les lieux de culte et
toutes les écoles de france
c'est ce qui malheureusement faudrait
faire mais imaginez la mentalité de
citadelle assiégée dans laquelle on
trouve riom donc je pense qu'il faut
défendre nos valeurs
il faut rester ferme et rappeler que nos
libertés ne sont pas négociables
alors les réactions ah bon depuis
ce matin et c'est cette cet acte qui
s'est donc déroulée à nice au moins
trois personnes sont morts beaucoup de
réactions politiques parmi elles la
droite elle rassemblement national qui
réclame une nouvelle méthode et ne les
lisent législation d'exception pour
faire face à une situation de guerre ce
sont les mots alexis poule en est ce que
c'est réaction à vif sur le coup de
l'émotion alors que les faits se sont
déroulés à 9 heures il y à peine trois
heures est ce qu'elles vont pousser et
ce qu'elles vont avoir un impact qu elle
en pâte est ce qu'elles peuvent avoir
sur les autorités françaises sur
l'exécutif qui vous l'avez rappelé tout
à l'heure on fait preuve la semaine
dernière ou en tout cas ont affiché un
volontarisme dans ce combat mené contre
le terrorisme bien peu importe les
déclarations politiciennes
aujourd'hui il ya une dynamique qui a
été enclenchée par l'exécutif par le
gouvernement qui est celle de la zéro
tolérance avec l'islamisme et le
radicalisme aujourd'hui sur le
territoire donc cette dynamique ne va
être que renforcée le problème c'est la
réponse que nous allons avoir en face
face à ces djihadistes improvisé qui
vont multiplier les attaques au couteau
qui vont user la patience des
populations civiles donc raison garder
dans la réponse policière militaire et
celle du renseignement raison garder
aussi au sein de la population française
pour éviter que les appels à la guerre
sainte aux guerres de religion guerre
civilisationnelle ne soit pas écouté ni
entendu parce que ce serait rentré dans
le jeu des terroristes et faire qu'ils
auraient gagné que de rentrer dans cette
logique de bière civilisationnel donc il
va falloir simplement maintenant que
gérald darmanin renforce les moyens
donnés aux renseignements en force les
moyens donnés à la police et qu'on
puisse s'assurer finalement d'une
vigilance de chaque instant
mais c'est les français aussi qui vont
vivre avec ce poids quotidien qui le
font depuis les attentats de 2015 les
mêmes ceux d'avant je crois que c'est
cette répétition cette fatigue de fait
peut être la france soit sujette d'attac
mais la france mais encore une fois je
rappelle d'autres pays européens sont
victimes d'attaqués au couteau la grande
bretagne
l'allemagne la suède et est encore
ailleurs voilà c'est l'usure en fait la
résilience des populations qui est mise
à mal
et pour que cette résilience durée que
les populations se sentent rassurés
l'état oui doit avoir une réponse forte
c'est ce qui a été initié ces derniers
jours et qui va s'amplifier je pense
dans l'est dans les semaines qui
viennent
merci beaucoup alexis poulain
éditorialistes